today we're going to be speaking with
gene guerrero who's author of
hate monger stephen miller donald trump
and the white nationalist
agenda uh great to have you on gene
great to be here so first just to start
with before we get into
really the substance if people don't
know who stephen miller is
uh if they pay attention to the things
trump says
a lot of those come from the mind of
stephen miller and sometimes from the
pen
of stephen miller but who who is this
guy how did he get involved with donald
trump
exactly you know stephen miller is not
only one of trump's top speechwriters he
is also
the immigration policy architect so he's
a senior policy advisor for trump with a
major focus on the immigration issue but
you see him shaping his rhetoric
on on pretty much everything and he is
a jewish american who comes from santa
monica california
and he got involved with the trump
campaign after working
with alabama senator jeff sessions and
and various other people in congress for
a little while
um and and really becoming interested in
you know a person who who he felt was
was
not politically correct and who gave
voice to a lot of the feelings that he'd
had ever since he was a teenager
you know stephen miller from the time
that he he was a teenager in santa
monica he would go around
his his his very diverse high school
telling his mexican classmates to go
back to their countries
telling them to speak english he broke
up with a mexican friend
telling him he couldn't be friends with
someone with a latino heritage
um so he was he was from a very young
age expressing these kinds of beliefs
when
and when he heard trump talking about
mexicans as rapists and criminals he got
very excited and
started to contribute free labor to his
campaign in the form of talking points
in the form of
immigration policies and eventually got
hired
how does someone like stephen miller end
up
given where he was born and given i mean
you know as a jewish
latino american myself i can say that
you know jews in the united states a
very reliably left-wing group 75 80
even 85 support of democratic presidents
in the past
uh i don't i'm involved in all sorts of
national jewish groups i've never met
anyone who would even consider
working for someone like jeff sessions
who even if for jewish republicans would
be almost too far
to really get involved and how does a
california guy like this end up with
these beliefs
well david i i really see it as a case
study and radicalization
um you know when he was a teenager he
was going through a very hard time his
family had lost a lot of money
related to their real estate company
they had to move
from a very affluent part of santa
monica
uh to a slightly less affluent and more
diverse part stephen miller ends up
having to go to a public
high school instead of a mostly white
private high school
and you know during this time period he
meets this man named david horowitz
who is a former marxist turned
right-wing radical
who was writing things at the time about
how
the only real racism is racism
against white men that racism against
black and brown people is a figment of
your imagination
that everything that we hold dear in
society in as americans
is a result of white men things like
justice equality
uh freedom that these are all thanks to
to white
men and so these are ideas that he
introduced stephen miller to
he ends up becoming like a father figure
to stephen miller
and teaching him the weapons of the
civil rights movement as a person who
came from the left
in order to attack the civil rights
movement so he taught stephen miller how
to invert
and deflect the language of the left
casting white men
as victims of discrimination based on
their skin color
casting people of color as the real
racists or the real oppressors
and this is language that stephen miller
used throughout his career
david horowitz got him his first jobs in
in congress
um you know first with tea party
congresswoman michelle bachmann and then
with
john chidag of arizona and finally with
uh jeff sessions
of alabama but he but he introduced him
to these
really white supremacist ideas and how
to launder them
through the language of heritage and the
language of national security and the
language of economics in order to make
these ideas palatable
to the mainstream which is what stephen
miller has been doing
in the speeches of donald trump um over
the course of his his time working for
him
this question might apply more generally
than just to stephen miller but
there's this incredible irony of someone
who is part of a group
that was not considered white by
the white european oppressors for so
long right
jews were the whole much anti-semitic
discrimination is based on the other
jews are not white
jumping in full bore to
repeat the talking points that were
essentially used
against jews that that and that's really
probably a broader phenomena that we see
among some on the right
exactly you know he takes ideas directly
from white nationalist and white
supremacist literature this has been
documented you know emails i've reviewed
of his
strategy papers that he's worked on and
these are
groups that not only vilify and and
promote violence against
people of color but they feel the same
way about the jewish people
and it's a it's a real conflict that
exists inside of stephen miller
most of his family is appalled at what
he's been doing in the white house
as far as the rhetoric and the policies
which largely
target immigrants who are fleeing
persecution and violence in their home
countries
you know stephen miller's grandmother on
his mother's side ruth
she spent her retirement um compiling
the family history
so that stephen miller and her other
grandchildren would never forget
the value of people who come to this
country in nothing but the clothes on
their back and speaking no english which
is how stephen miller's
great grandparents came here from
eastern europe fleeing
a persecution fleeing nationalist
agitators
um in eastern europe and and she also
recorded for him
the lessons of of you know the dangers
of demonization
and these are lessons that that most
people in the jewish community
you know value and understand how
important they are but their lessons
with stephen miller from the time that
he
he was young has been not only ignoring
but but directly
attacking and it's worth noting that his
mentor david horowitz is also
you know a jewish man and and he you
know
he he's he he's sort of his entryway
into white nationalist
uh ideologies which which he would you
know he he constantly says he's not a
white nationalist he's not a racist but
if you look at his
his writings they're very much um
echoing these white nationalist talking
points
um but he but anyway he he starts out
with this very anti-palestine
anti-arab anti-muslim mentality
and eventually you know stephen miller
broadens that out to include
all all immigrants but this is why you
saw one of the first actions that he
took in the white house
was the muslim ban um and and then
eventually you know
the systematic separation of of migrant
children from their parents
and the systematic dismantling of the
asylum system at the u.s mexico border
and and the destruction of the refugee
admissions
system as it exists in the united states
most of these policies
have impacted people seeking legal
pathways into this country
because they are desperate because you
know they're facing death threats at
home
this is not about criminals and cartels
crossing the border sneaking across the
border
illegally um stephen miller's policies
disproportionately impact
families who are trying to do things the
legal way
yeah this is not ms-13 as donald trump
often likes to talk about at rallies
well and that's something that stephen
miller inserts into trump's speeches he
knows that ms-13
he is like this you know thing the
symbol that he can use to rally people
around policies that harm
families overall but yeah i mean
the reason that these policies work this
way is because he's pulling them
directly from
think tanks created by a man named john
tanton
a eugenicist who believed in population
control for non-white people
a white supremacist who believes in the
genetic superiority of whites
and these think tanks like the
federation for american immigration
reform
you know they they they seem innocuous
they have very banal sounding
intellectual names but they exist to
to read to find ways to dismantle
uh legal pathways into this country for
people from latin america
and africa so to zoom out a little bit
very often when the topic of of the
trump administration and trump's
rhetoric and white nationalism comes up
you will hear these sort of reflexive
defenses about
uh trump's son-in-law is jewish and his
uh
you know daughter converted his
grandkids are jewish and that type of
thing when i
interviewed white nationalist richard
spencer years ago
during the trump administration he said
that
he doesn't expect trump to actually come
out and say
things exactly the way he says them
but that he sees trump as sort of like
the closest
thing to his ideology although more
recently spencer
himself has said they're kind of done
with trump and okay fine we can move
past that
but mike my question more broadly is
what are the ways
in which donald trump's language may be
even
unknown to trump because it's being
inserted by miller it doesn't matter
what are the ways in which trump has
sort of signaled to these groups that at
least to some degree he's their guy
well to start with a more recent example
i mean trump
for his relevant strategy has been
really working to conflate anti-racist
protesters and black lives matter
protesters with
quote agitators and anarchists and mobs
who want to destroy this country
that language of agitators and
anarchists referring to anti-racist
protesters
comes directly from a book called the
camp of the saints
which stephen miller promoted through
breitbart in 2015 and which is about the
destruction of the white world by brown
people described as monsters and beasts
and teeming ants toiling for the white
man's comfort
and that this book explicitly endorses
hatred and violence against people of
color as a
survival mechanism so it promotes the
conspiracy theory of white genocide that
has motivated so many acts of white
supremacist terrorism
including the el paso massacre that we
saw last august where 23
people were killed by a man who thought
he was saving the united states from a
quote hispanic invasion um and so
so so his language is is really dog
whistling
if you can even call it i don't think
it's even necessarily dog whistling i
think it's
directly echoing with the white genocide
theory are there other examples in terms
of trump specific lines i mean early
there was
you know looking at the origins of
america first and it sounds relatively
benign and
uh you know how could something just so
so so uh uh simple
uh have the this horrible origin uh so
so to speak are there other examples you
think are the relevant ones to think
about
yeah so so what a very common recruiting
tactic in white supremacist circles is
to use
uh to highlight um you know examples of
alleged crimes committed by people of
color and this is something that trump
has been doing from the very earliest
stages of the campaign
and he started out with this sort of
more instinctual emotional
racism saying that mexicans were were
criminals and rapists but when
stephen miller joined he he started to
really use very graphic
gory descriptions of alleged migrant
crimes that really works to incite white
fear and white hatred
an example being you know referring to
migrants
slashing people with machetes or
crushing a woman's eye sockets with a
hammer
um you know butchering little girls
language that is extremely violent and
is and is meant
to to provoke you know real sense of
fear that is something that comes from
stephen miller
also the use of false migrant crime
statistics saying that
you know thousands of americans have
been murdered by
by elite quote illegal immigrants this
is
this is false you know immigrants
whether they come to this country
legally or illegally are actually less
likely to commit crimes
than citizens but but trump
constantly uses false statistics about
immigrants and this is stephen miller
pulling from the white supremacist
recruiting tactics that he's familiar
uh websites like american renaissance uh
which he has been
um you know inspired by for for several
years and which uses this tactic of
highlighting migrant crimes and and
pumping out false and misleading
uh crimes attacks crime statistics about
migrants as well as black people
uh the book is fascinating it's called
hate monger stephen miller donald trump
and the white nationalist
agenda we've been speaking with the
book's author gene guerrero
uh so great to talk to you and i really
appreciate your time and and the
the book is excellent thank you so much
david